[Musique]
la presse quotidienne régionale et les
télévisions locales vous
présentent le club des
territoires et avec nous pour ce club
des territoires Catherine Morin de
bonjour merci d'être là sénatrice
centrice de la scène maritime
conseillère régional de Normandie rou
présider la commission culture et
ancienne présidente de la commission de
la culture et de l'éducation ici au
Sénat merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
sorelle bonjour merci d'être là
également essayer C ancienne membre du
collège du Haut conseil à l'intégration
et jeanrémy Gérard bonjour vous êtes le
président du SNAL le sindicat national
des lycées collèges école et du
supérieur le syndicat des personnels de
l'Éducation nationale on va parler avec
vous des inquiétudes et des menaces qui
pèsent sur l'école de nouveau mise en
lumière par l'attentat d'arace et la
mort du professeur Dominique Bernard les
professeurs sont-ils aujourd'hui en
danger sont-ils suffisamment protégé la
laïcité est-elle aujourd'hui menacée et
la fermeté affichée de Gabriel Atal
est-elle suffisante on débattra de tous
ces sujets et Quentin on parlera aussi
de la sécurité des établissements
scolaires voilà exactement avec des
initiatives dans les régions et aussi
bien le gouvernement qui fait des
propositions on va voir tout ça
précisément et voilà pour le programme
on débute tout de suite ce
[Musique]
club et on commence par notre reportage
à votre rencontre après l'attaque
terroriste dans un lycée d'aras le débat
sur la sécurité dans les établissements
scolaires est relancé notamment dans les
lycées en ronalp le président de la
Région Laurent vqu en a fait une de ses
priorités depuis 2016 110 millions
d'euros ont été investis on regarde ce
reportage de Jérôme
Rabier c'est un établissement flamban
neuf une vitrine aux yeux de la région
Auvergne ronalp qui en a financé sa
construction le lycée colonel Arnaud
Beltram à mes yeux en banlieu lyonnaise
a ouvert ses portes en septembre avec
toute la panoplie sécuritaire dernier
cré donc voici le premier s de contrôle
du lycée donc les élèves ont une carte
une carte qui leur permet de pouvoir
rentrer et sortir du tablissement cette
carte est déjà programmée par par
nous-mêmes sur les entrées et sorties ça
nous permet de connaître le nombre
d'élèves qui est présent dans
l'établissement de du personnel aussi
puisque chaque personnel a une carte
aussi pour ceux qui auraient oublié leur
carte un contrôle est aussi effectué par
le personnel d'éducation aux heures
d'entrée et de sortie un outil complété
par la vidéosurveillance installé un peu
partout dans l'établissement on a dit
camé qui qui circule le sens de
circulation des élèves c'est pas
l'intérieur de l'établissement et
notamment les entrées donc on a des
caméras qui qui sont placés ici pour
pouvoir visionner toute la cour et
notamment aussi tout le tout le local
vélo des personnels et des élèves et
l'entrée des portiques et aussi l'entrée
de l'accueil des personnes extérieures
qui doivent se présenter pour présenter
leur identité dire avec qui ils ont
rendez-vous pour qu'ils puissent rentrer
dans l'établissement La provoviseur a un
accès direct à ses images depuis son
bureau mais c'est surtout à l'accueil de
l'établissement qu'on coordonne cette
surveillance aujourd'hui vous avez pas
eu ai de cartes pas de souci au niveau
des caméras il y a tout tout fonctionne
bien tout fonctionne très bien là vous
avez le parvis de qui est juste devant
et puis vous avez aussi là un peu plus
loin dans la cour les
passerelles et puis sur le devant vous
avez le côté personnel là aussi quand il
y a un incident on on va regarder et on
relie on relie l'image ou bien sûr
expérimenté qui a connu des lycées avec
peu de sécurité tous ces équipements
sont devenus indispensables mais il faut
veiller à un équilibre moi je pense que
ça ça vise à
rassurer bah les élèves les familles les
enseignants effectivement parce que au
vu de ce qui se passe dans l'actualité
c'est quand même rassurant de voir que
on ne rentre pas comme dans un moulin
dans un établissement dans un
établissement public faut pas bonquiser
sanctuiriser l'école non plus parce
qu'on reste l'école et c'est quand même
important de pas que ce soit pas trop
anxiogène et créer une psychose aussi si
les nouveaux lycées comme celui-ci à mes
yeux disposent d'emblé de tout
l'équipement la région a aussi lancé
depuis 2016 un investissement massif
pour sécuriser les établissements qui ne
bénéficient pas de ces portiques ou
caméras de
vidéosurveillance une priorité de
l'exécutif dirigé par Laurent voquier
est relayé par son adjoint à la sécurité
on a cinq piliers fondamentaux pour
protéger n nos lycées c'est la sécurité
périmétrique des lycées le contrôle des
accès la sécurisation des entrées
principales et secondaires la
vidéosurveillance et la mise en place
des des plans de mise en sûreté avec les
alarmes et les messages en cas
d'intrusion la région a déjà investi 110
millions d'euros depuis 2016 pour la
sécurisation des lycées le renvo quiier
appel à généraliser dans le pays
l'exemple de la région qu'il dirige et
même d'aller plus loin en expérimentant
la reconnaissance faciale la proximité
des établissements une proposition bien
moins consensuelle jeanémy Gérard c'est
le bon exemple on voit que Laurent vqué
et la région vindronalpe investi
lourdement dans la sécurité des lcé on
va parler de la région Normandie
évidemment c'est le bon exemple qu'on
vient de voir il faut un diagnostic
sécurité de chaque établissement pour
savoir ce qu'on doit faire dans chaque
établissement là on est dans des lycées
il y a des moyens les régions ont
généralement plus de moyens qu'une
qu'une commune dans une école primaire
euh donc si les toursniquets là on a vu
les tourniquets sont une bonne solution
pour un établissement oui ça peut être
quelque chose de bien d'ailleurs mon mon
chef d'établissement en demande depuis 3
ans à sa région et ne pas euh maintenant
ça veut pas dire que il y a une solution
miracle pour tous les établissements il
y a des endroits si par exemple c'est
pas assez large où les tourniquets ça va
créer ça va créer au contraire un goulet
d'étranglement et et des attroupements
c'est pour ça que nous au SNAL on
demande un diagnostic sécurité de chaque
établissement et école afin euh qu'on
puisse déterminer comment on fait dans
tel endroit pour queun individu
extérieur ne puisse pas s'introduire
sans être identifié et contrôl
auparavant catherrine Morin de sa vous
êtes conseill régional de Normandie la
Normandie aussi hein qui investit sur la
sécurisation des lycées oui tout à fait
et on na pas attendu malheureusement les
les événements tragiques à nouveau
survenus il y a quelques jours pour avec
les établissements réfléchir aux
meilleures conditions d'accueil faire en
sorte s que les écoles les lycées
notamment soient sécurisé et en même
temps pas transformé non plus en en en
bnker c'est ça bien sûr l'enjeu nous
avons équipé plusieurs lycées en
fonction de chaque établissement vous
avez raison de dire il faut un
diagnostic sécurité parce que il y a
différents types d'établissements plus
ou moins anciens plus ou moins nouveaux
et donc faut s'adapter mais par exemple
la vidéo protection est aussi une
manière de sécuriser les entrées et les
allées et venu c'est qui qui prend la
décision est-ce que ce sont les chefs
d'établissement ou est-ce que ce sont
les les élus pu en Normandie on débat au
Conseil d'Administration de chaque lycée
d'accord est-ce qu'il faut aller plus
loin est-ce qu'il faut aller jusqu'à la
reconnaissance faciale il y a des
expérimentations qui ont cours à l'heure
actuelle notamment dans l'Académie de de
Nice je pense qu'il faut observer ce
qu'elles vont donner elles se font je
tiens à le dire sous le contrôle de
lacnil c'est extrêmement important aussi
qu'il a un respect euh dû à la à la vie
privé mais ne généralisons pas avant
d'avoir expérimenté de façon extrêmement
précise ouais Malica Sorel il est dur à
trouver cet équilibre entre en même
temps évidemment sécuriser les écoles
sécuriser les élèves et et les
enseignants et ne pas transformer
l'école en bunker comme le disait un
bunker ce qu'on a vu excusez-moi j'ai le
cœur brisé quand je vois ça c'està dire
que pour moi ça ce n'est plus ma douce
France celle que je je voulais retrouver
lorsque je suis revenue vivre en France
parce que je suis née en France j'ai
grandi puis je suis parti étudi en
Algérie c'est un bon cœur excusez-moi
mais un élève qui rentre j'ai eu
l'impression je me suis dit il manque
plus que les les les tapis puis on
enlève les ceintures à l'aéroport vous
voyez là pour on ouvre tous les sacs
donc non là on réagit en aval et je je
veux saluer la mémoire d'Arnaud Beltram
j'ai vu que le l'établissement s'appelle
Arnaud Beltram donc j'avais rencontré sa
sa mère c'est c'est déchirant de voir
son nom comme ça on agit en avale
excusez-moi c'est-à-dire qu'il y a un
problème et on se dit ah sécurité
partout mais il faut réfléchir aux
causes qu'est-ce qui nous a amené à cela
parce que il y a des moyens colossaux
qui vont être investis dans une époque
où la France a dégringolé nous sommes
derniers en mathématiques teams et donc
il y a des moyens considérables à mettre
à ce niveau-là que ce soit pour le
l'apprentissage des élèves pour soit la
condition matérielle des enseignants et
donc on va dépenser des fortunes pour la
question sécurité et je vais attirer
votre attention sur un point c'est que
c'était un ancien élève du lycée d'abord
l'assassinat s'est passé en dehors de
l'établissement donc déjà ça ne répond
pas à au drame que nous venons de de
vivre drame que sa famille vit parce
qu'on dit nous sommes tous un tel non
non non c'est lui qui est mort c'est sa
famille qui aujourd'hui souffre donc
nous sommes tous un tel un peu léger et
donc ça ne répond pas à ça et autre
chose moi j'ai des enfants s'ils avaient
voulu en S en quittant leur lycée
revenir même 2 ans après on les aurait
laissé rentrer ils auraient dit bonjour
je veux voir mon prof est-ce que je peux
rentrer mais il rentre donc c'est pas
possible j'ai j'ai vu un chef
d'établissement dire également
excusez-moi mais aux heures de grande
entrée et vous en avez parlé on peut pas
faire un goulot d'étranglement et chaque
élève qui passe ça et la reconnaissance
faciale excusez-moi je je suis pas sûr
de non je je pense que ça ne répondra
pas à la question parce que d'abord le
drame s'est passé en dehors et puis que
de toute façon un élève qui rentre avec
un couteau bah il le produira à
l'intérieur madame a raison sur le fond
quand on est élu en responsabilité
malgré tout faut qu'on réponde de
manière conjoncturelle sur les causes
sur les causes attendez je termine
madame bien sûr il faut qu'on puisse
répondre concrètement aux parents qui
s'inquiètent aux enseignants bref à la
communauté éducative et qu'on protège
les enfants mais ça ne résout rien je
suis tout à fait d'accord avec vous et
qu' il faut réfléchir au au aux causes
plus fondamentales pourquoi l'école
aujourd'hui qui de être un sanctuaire
qui doit être respecté en tant que tel
pourquoi elle est l'objet désormais
d'attaqu répété et notamment ces
enseignant et on va en parler mais
Quentin pour finir sur la sécurité des
établissements scolaires puisqueaprès
l'attaque d' race Malica Sorel le
rappelé c'est un des tout premiers
éléments tout premier sujet don
l'exécutif s'est saisi avec les
collectivités voilà les collectivités
locales qui sont au cœur de cette
discussion on l'a bien compris on l'a
compris aussi dans le dans le reportage
de de jérô ce sont les régions qui ont
la compétence des lycées on le rappelle
et les départements et bien qui gèent
les collèges mais plus généralement
Gabriel hatal a réuni toutes les
collectivités locales c'était mercredi
dernier il y avait toutes les
associations d'élus autour de la table
région département mais aussi les maires
de France les petites villes et à la clé
ce communiqué que je voulais vous
montrer sans annonce concrète mais cette
phrase l'objectif est clair il est
partagé par tous agir dans le cadre de
nos compétences respectives pour la
sécurité de nos établissements et donc
de nos élèves et de la communauté
éducative les mots importants c'est bien
sûr dans nos compétences respectives on
voit bien que les collectivités locales
qui revendiquent davantage de
responsabilités et de décentralisation
veulent garder la main aussi dans ce
dossier et on l'a vu il y a une relance
donc pas d'annonce j'ai la deuxième
foisci donc pas d'annonce c'est ça donc
pas d'annonce concrète pour ce qui est
de la réunion de de la semaine dernière
effectivement Orian le communiqué qui
mentionne une future rencontre pour
avancer et il faudra attendre et bien
après les vacances scolaires qui ont
commencé vendredi dernier les changement
pourrait donc intervenir à la rentrée du
6 novembre il faut donc attendre pour
voir aussi comment chaque collectivité
avance dans le dossier chaque
collectivité car on voit qu'au sein
d'une même famille politique on ne
propose pas les mêmes choses on avait
parlé de l'exemple de Laurent voquier en
overn ronalp avec donc ces logiciels de
reconnaissance faciale qu'il veut
développer autour des lycées il s'agit
pour lui je cite de détecter les
individus suivis pour radicalisation
terroriste on l'a vu dans cet article de
la montagne mais regardez approche
différente pour Valérie PCR en
île-de-fance qui elle dit que rien ne
remplace la présence humaine c'est ce
qu'elle avait dit dans Le Parisien à
propos de ce travail en parallèle entre
l'État et les collectivités locales
écoutz le ministre de l'éducation
nationale c'était sur BFM TV
avant-hier il faut le cadre national et
ça je viens de vous le rappeler et ce
cadre national c'est on ne doit pas
pouvoir pénétrer dans un établissement
scolaire quand on a rien à y faire et si
quelqu'un cherche à y pénétrer ou
malheureusement réussi à y pénétrer il
faut que tout de suite les élèves
puissent être confinés et protégés et
que les force de sécurité arrive au plus
vite une fois qu'on a dit ça territoire
par territoire les élus qui sont
responsable de la sécurité de ces
bâtiments mettre en place les mesures
appropriées je les ai réunis cette
semaine ils sont particulièrement
mobilisés sur ce sujet je vais leur
partager les données de l'enquête que
j'ai diligenté et j'aurai les données
demain pour qu'il puisse savoir
précisément ce qu'il a à conduire en
matière de mise au niveau dans dans
leurs établissements pour qu'on puisse
avancer madame Maurin de sa c'est ça qui
se joue c'est chaque région en fait qui
va avoir ces bouquet de mesure c'est
bien ça oui et selon aussi la
particularité des des établissements
c'est ce que nous évoquions tout à
l'heure il est important de regarder
voilà la configuration aussi de de
chaque établissement je vrais insister
sur les moyens humains parce qu'on a
parlé beaucoup d'équipement de
reconnaissance faciale de portique mais
il convient aussi d'avoir les personnes
voilà en présence aussi ad hoc à
l'entrée des lycées tout simplement
parce que d'abord c'est aussi l'accueil
des enfants tout simplement et des
familles le le matin et en même temps je
crois que c'est une présence qui est
efficace et et rassurante donc
l'éducation nationale elle est chargé de
mettre à disposition les moyens et ça on
attend parfois les moyens ou qu'est-ce
que vous attendez vous jeanamigérard de
de ce qui va sortir de ces discussions
Gabriel hatal dit qu'il a aucun tabout
très bien nous on attend on attend de
voir ce que ça donne surtout mais la
difficulté qu'on a sur cette question et
on est bien d'accord que la question de
la sécurisation des établissements c'est
pas l'alpha et l'oméga de ce qui se
passe à l'école et c'est pas non plus
l'alpha et l'oméga de la lutte contre le
terrorisme néanmoins la difficulté qu'on
a c'est qu'en fait comme les compétences
sont déconcentrées que c'est chaque
collectivité locale qui s'occupe de
chaque niveau on a des réponses qui sont
parfois d'affichage qui sont parfois
parfois contrairement peut-être à ce qui
se passe dans votre région d'ailleurs
qui sont parfois non concertés du tout
avec les personnels qui connaissent les
établissements et qui savent ce dont ils
ont besoin c'est formidable de mettre
des caméras de sécurité s'il y a
personne pour les regarder et on parlait
de la présence humaine ça ne sert
strictement à rien c'est pour ça qu'on
doit écouter les personnels de
l'Éducation nationale qui sont ceux qui
connaissent le mieux leur établissement
ainsi que les agents de la région qui
travaillent ou les agents du Département
qui travaillent à l'intérieur des
établissements pour pouvoir trouver
effectivement le fonctionnement adapté
et ne pas lancer dès qu'il se passe
quelque chose euh voilà des mesure
j'allais dire politico-politicienne là
on VO on va mettre des maîtres chiens
des porties de détection de métaux enfin
ça n'a aucun sens moi je sais pas à quoi
sert un maître chien devant un lycée par
exemple donc peut-être qu'il faudrait
effectivement avoir cette concertation
pour avoir à un moment quand même une
cohérence dans les réponses et
effectivement les financements
nécessaires par exemple on sait que les
écoles primaires les écoles maternelle
il y a pas forcément beaucoup d'argent
au niveau de la mairie à mettre dedans
euh mica Sorel vous vous le disiez
évidemment il faut parler de la sécurité
mais il faut aussi s'attaquer aux causes
on l'a vu avec l'attaque d'aras que les
professeurs étaient une nouvelle fois
des cibles et qu'ils sont aujourd'hui
une cible du terrorisme la sœur de
Samuel Patti elle était devant les
sénateurs la semaine dernière et elle a
dit si la mort de son frère avait servi
à quelque chose Dominique Bernard le
professeur d'aras ne serait pas mort
vous le pensez aussi absolument moi a
tout à fait raison tout à fait je je
voudrais seulement dire un point avant
de répondre à votre question avant de
réagir ce que vous venez de dire qui est
très fort et de ce qu'a dit la la sœur
de Samuel pati que la présidente de
région de France dit il faut de la
présence humaine excusez-moi mais a-t-on
vu les mêmes les mêmes images les mêmes
vidéos il y a des enseignants un agent
aussi qui a essayé d'arrêter le
terroriste il y en a qui sont fait
poignarder donc il y avait de la
présence humaine il avait été convoqué
par l'antiterrorisme la veille donc il
faut qu'on arrête de se voiler la face
il y avait la présence humaine nous
sommes face à un problème extrêmement
compliqué moi j'ai déjà échangé ah mais
tout le le monde politique se voit la
face dans les médias un peu partout dans
la société pendant très longtemps on on
se voiler la face je je je vous donne un
exemple donc donc arrêtons de dire il
suffit une présence humaine que
voulez-vous qu'un enseignant ou un
contrôleur à l'entrée du collège ou
lycée euh face face à quelqu'un qui
vient qui est déterminé qu' avit un
couteau on a vu la succession le
professeur de philo à qui il pose la
question il dit vous êtes prof
d'histoire Gou il dit non et du coup il
l'épargne et en réalité ceux qui ont été
poignardés et ça ceux qui travaillent
dans ces sujets doivent bien écouter ce
que je vais dire ceux qui ont été
poignardés ou qu'il a voulu poignarder
sont ceux qu' ont tenté de s'opposer à
lui tous ceux qui ont fait ça qui sont
reculé il les a pas attaqué je ferme la
parenthèse en 2012 dans un rapport du au
Conseil l'intégration nous parlions déjà
de laaba qu'est-ce qui s'est fait depuis
et nous disions certains chefs
d'établissement s'interroge sur le fait
que ce soit une tenue religieuse ou pas
et nous disions il ne fait pourtant
aucun doute que c'est une tenue
religieuse et que ça tombe sous
l'application de la loi 2004 et qu'il
s'agit d'interdire ce ce vêtement
religieux parce que c'est un instrument
de prosélitisme ça exerce une pression
sur les autres filles qui se voilent pas
c'est une manière également de mettre la
République par terre il it problè d'
dans les éc bra 2012 2023 qu'on fait les
autres ministres rendez-vous compte le
temps que nous avons perdu c'est-à-dire
que à chaque fois nous avons renvoyé un
signal de faiblesse nous avons eu des
débats sans fin sur l'accompagnement des
maires voilé C Goolen royale lorsqu'elle
était ministre avait dicté une
circulaire elle avait bien dit c'est
interdit et d'ailleurs elle avait donné
les arguments pourquoi parce que le
personnel qui accompagne est protégé par
les assurances liées à l'éducation
nationale et donc dans ce moment-là ils
sont assimilés à du personnel
d'éducation et donc lo 2004 pourquoi
avons-nous tergiversé autant je termine
juste sur un point c'est important
absolument c'est le fait qu'il faut être
cohérent le 4
septembre lorsque Gabriel hatal a le
courage et je le salue de dire stop
laïcité l'école doit redevenir un
sanctuaire nous avons perdu beaucoup de
temps qu'est-ce qui se passe le même
jour le 4 septembre vous avez la
secrétaire d'État Sabrina Agresti rubach
qui dit alors que Gabriel Atal vient de
dire AB bah interdit elle passe à la
télé c'est sur TF1 et elle dit la loi
est dure mais c'est la loi alors je vais
vous dire comment c'est traduit par des
adolescents surtout lorsqu'ils sont
musulmans la loi est dure c'est traduit
la loi est injuste et donc ça crée des
sentiments de violence et elle continue
je termine avec ça elle dit moi je suis
une femme musulmane comment est-ce qu'un
membre du gouvernement peut se permettre
de dire je suis musulman je suis un tel
et elle dit et je suis pudique et en
Islam en langue arabe dans les sociétés
lorsqu'une femme sort non voilée non
couverte on dit qu'elle est nu
c'est-à-dire qu'elle est indécente et
donc ça c'est décrypté et donc il y a
déjà une incohérence au sein du
gouvernement avec un ministre qui défend
la République et une autre ministre qui
met en défaut la République et qui la
met en délicatesse Catherine main de je
partage tout ce que vous venez de dire
Madame parce que ces débats nous les
avons vécus au Sénat je présidit alors
la commission de la culture et de
l'éducation il y avait des tenants au
sein de notre assemblée de strictement
interdire tous SIG exter religieux
particulièrement le voile vous l'avez
exprimé j'avoue que la gauche de l' mque
a toujours été opposée à ces ces
interdictions malheureusement on a
perdompagnatrice scolaire oui mais de
façon générale et donc on a perdu
beaucoup de temps entre ceux qui pren
une laïcité stricte laïcité voilà
adjectivé vous avez raison une laïcité
et d'autres qui sous couvert de respect
des cultures des identités de certaines
communautés ont été faibles et on
laissait croire que l'on pouvait venir à
l'école ainsi donc moi je me réjouis de
la décision de de Gabriel tal qui
conforte les initiatives parlementaires
qui ont eu lieu vous le savez ici au au
au au Sénat mais je dois dire qu'on a
perdu beaucoup beaucoup de temps depuis
le début des années 2010 vous l'avez dit
Madame quand il y a eu cette affaire du
voile et que ce chef d'établissement n'a
pas du tout été soutenu et moi j'ai
rencontré un nombre de chefs
d'établissement que nous avons
auditionné qui a défaut d'instruction
clairire nette et et précise laisser
àors libre administration la gestion de
cette situation locale se sont trouvé
extrêmement démunis or la règle la loi
de la République elle est la même pour
tous et vous avez raison de le souligner
le vrai sujet c'est quand même l'AD
islamisme pardonnez-moi qu'il faut
combattre avec tenacité c'est bien
au-delà de
l'école que le combat se se situe je
crois que c'est un combat de
civilisation nos sociétés occidental
aujourd'hui dans leur modèle qui sont le
modèle de l'héritage des des lumières et
bien sont sont en comment dirais-je
combattu par un obscurantisme et des
fanatiques forcennés qui en veulent un
notre modèle de civil humiliation dans
le cadre duquel la
liberté peut-être dépasse les
transcendances religieuses ouais
Jean-Rémy Gérard est-ce que aujourd'hui
la laïcité recule à l'école c'est pas
forcément facile euh de faire comprendre
à beaucoup de nos élèves ce qu'est la
laïcité telle qu'elle est définie dans
la République française euh parce que
l'école n'est pas la seule autorité
reconnue par nos élèves et n'est parfois
pas reconnu comme une autorité j'allais
dire comme une autorité philosophique
comme une autorité intellectuelle euh
parce que dans certains cas ça peut être
effectivement l'autorité familiale ça
peut être d'autres sources que ce soit
religieuse que ce soit les vidéos
consommées à grand rythme parfois aussi
par certains de nos élèves et du coup
même si j'aimerais quand même le dire
hein le travail éducatif qu'on fait il
est absolument indispensable et l'école
française va mal mal enfin si si elle
n'existait pas ça irait encore beaucoup
beaucoup plus mal dans la société on est
d'accord qu'il faut essayer de sauver
notre école parce que là aujourd'hui on
n'arrive plus à recruter d'enseignants
enfin on est dans une grande grande
grande difficulté néanmoins voilà il y a
des situations dans lesquels on pourrait
toujours faire 7 he par jour
d'enseignement moral et civique on ne
déradicalisera pas certains de nos
élèves et c'est pour ça que il y a un
travail qui est mené j'espère qu'il va
aller au bout euh au niveau de
l'éducation nationale avec le ministère
de l'Intérieur et on espère aussi le
ministère de la Justice pour essayer de
trouver enfin des réponses
interministérielles cohérente et
collective qui est de l'information qui
circule qu'à un moment s'il y a un nos
élèves qu'on voit quand même toute la
semaine s'il y a un nos élèves qui est
potentiellement dangereux il y a un
moment on est des fonctionnaires ce
serait important de nous le signal mais
vous dites on espère que ça ira jusqu'au
bout ça veut dire que vous en doutez
parce que Gabriel hatal il a l'air très
ferme sur ces sujets d'ailleurs il a dit
que les les 183 tris élèves qui avaient
préféré des menaces graves pendant la
minute d'hommage à Samuel pati à
Dominique Bernard ne ferit pas leur
rentrée ne 6 novembre prochain alors
c'est pas dé ou pas dter nous on est un
syndicat de l'éducation nationale on
protège les personnels nous on juge au
résultat donc bah c'est normal qu'ils
soit pas encore là on va pas on va pas
créer tout un système entre trois
ministères d'un claquement de doigt et
on est d'accord qu'on aurait peut-être
dû ans et c'est ça et ça c'est un point
très important parce que nous ce que
l'on entend de la part de nos collègues
euh c'est mais du coup il s'est passé
quoi depuis 3 ans et bien il s'est passé
pas grand-chose il s'est passé quelques
caméras de sécurité quelques
portiques ça n'a servit à rien d'ord
alors il s'agit pas de dire que ça n'
serv une fois encore on peut pas juger
d'une politique globale sur un cas
individuel et je suis entièrement
d'accord que notre collègue n'aurait
probablement pas été sauvé par une
caméra de sécurité on est bien d'accord
maintenant
entre l'état de d'un certain nombre
d'établissement aujourd'hui où on peut
rentrer absolument comme dans un moulin
absolument comme dans un moulin et euh
le risque zéro qui n'existera pas je
crois qu'il y a quand même des grosses
grosses marges de progression Quentin
sur la lacité sur l'autocensure
notamment oui on avait vu ce sondage de
de de l'Ifop qui signalit que voilà un
un enseignant sur deux s'autocensurait
n'évoquait pas certains sujets du
programme et dans ce sens on a vu
Gabriel Attal faire plusieurs annonces
lors de la séence des questions
d'actualité au Gouvernement c'était
mercredi dernier au Sénat au-delà de la
sécurisation des établissements au-delà
aussi et bien de tous ces élèves qui
n'avaient pas respecté l'hommage il a
annoncé d'autres choses comme par
exemple une formation pour tous les
personnels de l'Éducation nationale à la
laïcité d'ici 2027 il parle d'un million
de personnes à former d'ici 2027 de
mémoire il parle aussi de refondre le
programme de l'éducation civique
complètement et enfin j'avais retenu une
troisième annonce qu'il avait faite lors
de cette séance Mercredi dernier c'était
d'aller vers une généralisation du SNU
il voit ça aussi comme une des solutions
à la crise actuelle en tout cas ce sont
les pistes que luice nation universel
oui service national universel ça
répondra pas à la question je suis dés
ce sont les pistes mais est-ce que par
la
mais moi ça fait je crois que ça doit
faire 10 fois qu'on me promet une
formation à la lïité à chaque fois qu'il
y a un drame à chaque fois qu'il se
passe quelque chose dans l'actualité on
nous dit qu'on va avoir une formation à
la laïcité moi je suis enseignant depuis
2004 je n'ai jamais reçu une formation à
la laïité j jamais jamais alors ça se
fait il y a des académies là parce que
là aussi c'est déconcentré l'éducation
nationale sur beaucoup d'aspects je sais
que ma responsable valeur et principes
de la République au SNAL
elle elle signale queil y a un travail
de formation sur la laïcité qui se fait
qui est voilà moi je suis dans
l'académie de Versailles pourtant
l'académie de Versailles je crois que
c'est pas l'académie où ça se passe le
mieux je n'ai jamais reçu ça la plupart
de mes collègues n'ont jamais eu de
formation après manorelle tout ça
renvoie en réalité aux conditions
d'exercice du métier d'enseignant et se
poser les bonnes questions comment
revaloriser ce très beau métier le plus
beau du monde en réalité et donner aux
enseignants par pardonnez-moi
l'expression toutes les armes
nécessaires pour voilà faire classe dans
de bonnes conditions sereines et ça
c'est important la formation initiale et
continue est un vrai sujet elle est très
déficiente on l'a dit maines et mains de
fois notamment dans cet hémicycle marine
cassorel les enseignants ont eu une
formation c'est-à-dire que ils ont fait
des
études ils peuvent même parfaitement par
eux-même savoir ce que c'est que la
laïicité je pense
que pensez que parce qu'on va donner une
formation aux enseignants je dis pas
qu'il faut pas le faire si des
enseignants disent moi j'ai besoin ou on
a vu des enquêtes où des enseignants
disaient moi ça me dérange pas que les
personnes ne viennent avec leur signe
religieux à l'école c'est-à-dire que les
enseignants une parti ne veulent même
pas eux-mêmes appliquer la loi de la
République donc là où il y a un travail
à faire donc il a de la faiblesse de la
part du corps enseignant il y a de la
faiblesse de
la mais bien entendu lorsque j'étais au
conseil
d'intégration lorsque j'étais au conseil
d'intégration nous avions auditionné que
ce soit les les les syndicats
d'enseignants syndicats de parents
d'élèves et à l'époque c'était
l'accommodement déraisonnable c'était à
chaque fois non mais ça c'est pas grave
ça c'est pas grave on avait beau dire
non non mais attendez ça la République
c'est ça si vous faites pas respecter
demain ça sera autre chose je ferme la
parenthèse donc bien entendu qu'il y a
également une responsabilité et donc un
rôle à jouer par les enseignants
maintenant nous n'avons pas à demander
aux enseignants qu' déjà un programme
très chargé à transmettre parce qu'il
faut pas non plus oublier que la France
c'est aussi l'économie c'està-dire qu'il
faut transmettre des des savoirs pour
que demain nous puissions avoir des
ingénieurs et cetera on peut pas
demander aux enseignants de passer je ne
sais pas combien une dizaines d'heures
l'enseignement moral et civique tout en
sachant ils peuvent très bien dire aussi
aux élèves qui ne comprennent pas la
laïcité ils comprennent très bien je
peux vous dire ils sont très
intelligents ceux qui ont auditionné le
terroriste qui a assassiné Dominique
Bernard ont dit il est très intelligent
donc ils comprennent et c'est c'est pas
pour rien qu'ils attaquent la laïcité
donc il faut dire c'est comm ça ils
onont pas la même
vision ils ne la partageront pas
nécessairement ce qu'il faut c'est dire
ici c'est comme ça et ne pas laisser le
corps enseignant s'épuiser à essayer de
convaincre parce que là vous rentrez
dans de bras de fer dans les enseignants
sortiront pas gagnants il y a autre
chose à faire qui est très important
c'est le fait de d'abord de réaliser
qu'un certain nombre d'erreurs ont été
commises qu'il fallait mettre l'accent
sur la langue française tar benjeloun
avait bien dit que dans les années 70
lorsque le roi du Maroc a voulu empêcher
ce sont les termes de tar benjeloun
empêcher les Marocains de réfléchir il a
arabisé qu'on fait certains ministres
ils ont introduit la langue arabe au
lieu de renforcer l'enseignement du
français donc il a ça de rappeler la
laïcité ici c'est pas de signe religieux
il y a pas plus compliqué que ça
regardez ça prend quelques minutes et
c'est tout et vous respectez et la chose
la plus importante et si j'ai un message
à faire passer à Gabriel hatal c'est que
c'est pas la formation des enseignants
qui est importante c'est le fait de
cibler les parents parce qu'il y a déjà
des études et j'en ai toujours parlé
dans Mones livre de chercheurs qui
avaiit mis en évidence et je peux
confirmer que c'est vrai ce qu'ils
avaient écrit qu'il y a une obligation
d'obéissance des enfants envers leurs
parents et lorsque les enfants arrivent
à l'école et testent et même essaient de
démonter la République et Bentolila en
avait parlé dans le rapport qu'il avait
remis à Xav D'cos lorsque xavid D'cos
était ministre d'éducation nationale il
a pris le rapport d'Arcos il a jeté à la
poubelle c'est en 2009 il aurait dû s'en
occuper il était mentionné que le
problème principal que rencontrait
l'école et donc les enseignants c'était
l'incompatibilité entre la culture que
les parents transmettaient à la dans la
famille et l'école donc monsieur hatal
s'il vous plaît visez les familles ça
peut passer d'abord par les réprimandes
ensuite parce que moi j'avais fait
lorsque j'étais au Conseil inégration
suspension des aides sociales jusqu'à ce
que les parents comprennent qu'il
doivent s'exécuter on n'a pas essayé de
les convaincre il y a des règles comme
lorsque que dans une famille un parent
dit à son enfant c'est comme ça tu dois
te coucher à telle heure parce que
l'enseignant demain a besoin que tu sois
présent et attentif la conclusion
Catherine m de ça il reste 30 secondes
oui je crois qu'on demande beaucoup à à
l'école bon formation initiale à la
laïcité ça ça va de soi souvent les
enseignants ils sont formés avant tout à
leur discipline donc ça c'est important
mais au demeurant c'est comment on
redonne à l'école ce rôle extrêmement
important comment l'école est à nouveau
respectée alors ça passe par un vrai
sujet de réflexion sur sur le le statut
les conditions d'exercice aussi du du du
du métier d'enseignant çaag voilà voilà
il a tout ça je termine monsieur s'il
vous plaît mais je crois aussi que c'est
un débat de société comment on refait
nation comment les familles sont
responsabilisé comment on redonne à à la
France comment dirais-je ce cette cette
sérénité et surtout ce respect cette
cette tolérance et des règles du vivre
ensemble tout simplement comme vous
l'avez très justement évoqué madame et
ça c'est un vrai sujet aujourd'hui nous
av été fragmenté communautarisé ce n'est
pas tolérable et ce sera le mot de la
fin merci pour ce débat on regarde
qu'elle a une de nos quotidiens
régionaux avant de se
[Musique]
quitter Quentin on commence avec la
visite d'Emmanuel Macron en Israël voilà
tout à fait c'est à lire notamment dans
le douphin élibéré encore wouest France
journal de grenob par ex ce qui se
demande si cette vis ne relève pas d'une
mission impossible entre la libération
des otages la lutte contre l'extension
du conflit ou encore l'aide envoyée à
Gaza les enjeux de cette visite
s'annonce compliqué Bruno Le Maire donne
une interview au télégram voilà dans le
journal breton pour évoquer notamment le
potentiel économique de la région le
ministre de l'économie est en
déplacement à quimpè aujourd'hui
l'occasion aussi d'évoquer le dossier
des pêcheurs un sujet d'importance
effectivement en Bretagne puisque la
filière s'inquiète de la fin des aides
au carburant au début du mois de mais le
ministre explique dans l'interview être
en train de négocier avec la Commission
européenne la presse revient aussi sur
les dangers de certains médicaments
antirumes oui ce sont des médicaments
très connus si je vous dis dolyirume ou
actifet de rume on les voit et bien à la
Une de La Dépêche ou encore Var Matin
car l'Agence nationale de sécurité des
médicaments vous l'avez sans doute vu
hier appelle à ne plus les utiliser
c'est lié à des risques d'accidents
cardiovasculaire ces médicaments sont
pourtant disponibles sans ordonnance
mais ils font l'objet de critique depuis
plusieurs années compte ainsi Var Matin
dans ses pages intérieures l'agence
française qui a demandé à son homologue
européenne de réévaluer l'intérêt de ces
traitements puisque c'est au niveau de
l'Europe que ça se décide très
rapidement Quentin les vendang oui on
termine avec le Courrier de l'Ouest à
Angers puisque c'est une très belle
récolte je voulais finir voilà sur un
ton un peu plus léger mais cette année
la récolte s'annonce très belle voilà et
puis c'est à lire au
G merci Quentin un mot sur votre livre
manica Sorel mon dernier ouvrage oui le
son titre c'est les dindons de la farce
c'est-à-dire que dindon de la farce sont
les Français de souche culturell
européenne et tous ceux comme moi il y
en a d'autres qui ont fait le choix de
l'assimilation donc le choix de la
France comme patrie de cœur et d'esprit
et qui se retrouve aujourd'hui être les
dindons de la farce merci mal merci
jeanr merci Catherine Mor d'avoir été
avec nous pour ce débat merci Quentin
merci à tous de nous avoir suivi
prochain rendez-vous à 18h s public
Thomas HUG et nous on se retrouve demain
très bonne
journée